mais d'abord il a eu cette bonne
nouvelle les festivals en plein air
pourront se tenir
puis la moins bonne jauge limitée à 5000
spectateurs 5000 spectateurs assis voilà
qui ne colle pas du tout avec l'esprit
des festivals sans parler des chaises
par centaines alors l'envi sera t-elle
en rendez vous cette solution est elle
tenable financièrement pour l'instant
les organisateurs des très populaires
terres du son et au quart de tour sont
un peu dans le flou aurélie renault ces
images vous ne les verrez pas cet été
nous sommes au domaine de candé presque
quarante mille personnes défilent durant
trois jours pour le festival terres du
son en effet désormais les concerts vous
allez y assister sur une place assise
la nouvelle les organisateurs l'ont
apprise il y à quelques heures on
commence à sortir du flou sur certains
aspects c'est à dire que ça y est on a
une jauge alors une jauge à 6 sauf
qu'une jauge à 6 c'est pas vraiment
l'adn d'un festival on l'accueille aussi
de façon un peu positif on se dit que il
ya des choses quand même qu'ils sont
envisageables et on n'a pas dit notre
dernier mot
par contre sous quelle forme là il faut
qu'on y travaille on sait qu
économiquement ça ne sera pas viable ça
c'est une évidence notre d'autant plus
que si on ne peut pas faire de barney de
restauration et si ça se confirme
voilà on sait c'est une évidence ça sera
pas viable chaque année en juin le
festival aucard de tours lui se déploie
sur la plaine de la gloriette quatre
chapiteaux 100% musique amplifiée piloté
par béton production l'équipe avait revu
sa copie
la demie jauge bien sûr faisait partie
du plan b mais les places assises et
l'interdiction de bar et de restauration
n'était pas envisagée combien ça peut
coûter
comment est ce qu'on peut
on peut organiser un festival avec avec
des gradins et des chapiteaux qui sont
pas forcément compatibles les uns avec
les autres puisque nous on est partis
avec des avec des partenaires ou des
prestataires parce qu'on s'est un peu la
même chose
et est ce que ça va l'un correspond à
l'autre est ce que est ce que c'est
jouable aussi
et est ce qu'on a envie de le faire tous
collectivement c'est aussi ça parce que
il faut que tout le monde c'est une
équipe de bénévoles donc est ce qu'on a
envie de le faire tous collectivement
nous oui
- oui mais c'est aussi des questions
qu'on se pose parce que les contrats
n'ont pas de trop fortes
question les festivals sont ils prêts à
s'adapter à nouveau la ministre roselyne
bachelot a annoncé qu'une enveloppe de
30 millions d'euros seraient alloués
pour accompagner les festivals vers une
version alternative ou pour limiter la
casse en cas d'annulation